>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> So, for our next
authors coming to the stage,
we are going to have two it's
going to be like a little panel
and so we are going to have
Ellen Oh and Meg Medina,
and so do any of you have any
favorite stories you like to tell?
Just show me with a show of hands.
Do you have any favorite
stories you like to tell?
Anybody? Come on.
We all have our favorite
stories you know,
we talk about that one time we fell
down the stairs and the one time,
you know, we had milk shoot out
of our nose and things like that.
Okay, yeah me too.
Everybody has their favorite
stories, and so do these two people
who are coming to the stage.
They also have many of their
favorite stories to tell.
They've worked together to write
"Flying Lessons & Other Stories."
The people I mentioned are Ellen
Oh and Megan Medina who are two
of ten collaborators, that's
a big word, collaborators here
for their story collection;
ten people all working
together that's what the means,
"collaborating" working
together to write one pieces.
That's so, that's so much fun.
In this collection, is not only
funny, but it's also sweet.
So it makes your heart feel
like oh, you know, it's sweet.
This impressive group of authors
and these two who are here today,
they have earned among these
two and the other eight authors,
they've earned every major
award in children's publishing.
That is a lot of awards.
Let's give them a hand for that.
[ Applause ]
That's more awards than I can even
attempt to name in this intro.
And they've gained popularity
as New York Times bestsellers.
These distinguished authors
deliver a book full of ten unique
and vibrant stories
and I can't wait to see
which one's they've chosen
to share with us today.
Please give a warm welcome
to Ellen Oh and Meg Medina.
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
Hi everyone.
I'm kind of jealous
of your bing bags.
I want one up here.
[ Background Conversations ]
>> Should I just start
singing into; oh, it's one now.
Hi. I almost started
to sing a song for you
and then you would have run away.
Thank you all for coming.
We are here to talk
about this book called
"Flying Lessons & Other Stories"
and I'm the editor of this book.
It's an anthology and it's put
out by We Need Diverse Books
and Random House Crown Books for
Kids, and Meg Medina who is also one
of the, you know, founding
members of We Need Diverse Books.
It has her wonderful
story in here too.
So, does anybody know about
We Need Diverse Books?
Yeah. Wonderful.
So, we did this anthology
because we wanted to make sure
that there was a book
of stories that kind
of like represented
everyone's life experiences,
everyone's personal stories,
and to kind of let people know
that we are all the same as humans,
but with a diverse range of stories
and backgrounds and cultures,
and sharing those stories is
really the best way to kind
of like have an impact in the world
and get to know each other better.
So, I wanted to kind of talk about
who we're missing today though.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: We are missing
Tim Tingle and Kwame Alexander.
Kwame had a very sad
personal tragedy in the family
and so we miss; we will miss him
here today of course and Tim is
in Texas and we all know how
bad the situation is over there
and that's why he couldn't
come over.
So, Meg had this great idea, if you
don't mind, I can't take selfies,
but maybe she can take a selfie
of us with you guys is that okay
and we can say to Kwame and Tim?
>> Meg Medina: Her
arms are too short.
We're going to turn around and
we're going to take a picture
of you, so try to look good.
Okay?
>> Ellen Oh: Okay?
>> Meg Medina: And we're
going to tweet this;
we're going to send this Kwame and
Tim and tell them we're thinking
of them and we miss them.
Okay?
>> Ellen Oh: So, everybody say hi.
>> Meg Medina: So, look good.
Alright? Alright.
>> Ellen Oh: Don't
make fun of our backs.
>> Meg Medina: Are we ready?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, there's
a lot of them.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Alright.
>> Meg Medina: One, two, three.
>> Ellen Oh: Okay, immortalized.
I'll send it after we
finish talking today.
Thank you.
Okay, so one of the things about We
Need Diverse Books is that the idea
of having diverse stories
is really important
because stories are a
universal experience,
and I love this anthology because I
think what every author here did was
write a story that was
very personal to them;
something that they might not have
shared or something that really kind
of is reflective of a story that
they never saw for themselves
when they were younger and
I think that, you know,
the best way to start maybe
is to kind of talk about some
of the stories exactly in here.
And, let's see, what
are we going to do?
We, we're going to talk about
how do they, fiction and fact.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
Alright, so no matter what
you write as a writer even
if you're writing fiction,
you're not really too far
away from your truth ever.
So, things you remember from being
a kid, the person who scared you,
the person who loved you,
your favorite teacher,
your most horrifying
teacher, your best friend,
the friend that made your
life miserable last year,
etcetera-etcetera.
They all stay in there and I think
in these ten stories we all did
pretty much that, a version of that.
So, who was here this
morning when RJ Palacio came
to speak this morning,
raise your hand?
Yeah, I was here too.
I got up very early for that.
So, here's a funny thing that
Raquel and I, or RJ Palacio
and I were best friends
growing up in elementary school.
Which is a great friend;
she lived on a 160th Street
and lived on 158th Street.
Raquel's family is from Columbia
and my family is from Cuba
and so we were the only two
Latina girls in our class.
Now, we had lots of
different kids in our class.
We were very lucky that we
were in a school that had lots
of different backgrounds,
but we happened
to be the only two
Latina girls in the class.
So, I remember one time her
building was two blocks from mine
and they all looked the same.
Do any of you live like that?
We lived on a series of blocks
that were four buildings
that were exactly the same;
one, two, three, four.
I can tell them apart because of
the stoop and the names on the bells
and things like that,
but they were different.
You know, they were
basically the same building.
And one day, the police cars
came outside of Raquel's building
and then the ambulances came, and
then all the neighbors came out
and stood around like "what's
happening, what's happening?"
And the very sad thing
that happened is
that an older gentleman
had passed away.
He had died in his
apartment on the first floor.
Raquel lived on the first floor.
And so we were so afraid that
we had been in this building
with this dead body and
this man and we were,
it was just amazing watching
this whole thing transpire.
So, when Ellen came
to me and she said,
"Will you be in this anthology?"
And she's going to tell you all
about Soman and how that came to be.
I said, "Yes!
Of course."
And she said, "It's middle grade.
So you want to really write a story
that has to do with kids, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve in that age group."
And I thought, the dead
body in Raque's building.
So, when it came time to writing
"Sol Painting" that's
what I pulled from.
Should I do that paragraph?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: And this is what it
sounds like when you take something
from real life and then you mix it
all up and you make it into fiction
and this is just the
first paragraph.
"I reach inside the window of
Papi's van and I yank on the handle
to open the passenger door.
It's my turn to ride in front.
Roli sat there last time.
You think they'll need
a painter in there soon,
Papi asked as I slide
in next to him.
I follow his gaze to the second
floor of building twenty-two.
Men dressed like astronauts
are tossing furniture
into the tall canisters
that are marked "biohazard."
Dona Roza, one of the old
ladies who lived over there died
in her living room last week.
Her TV was on so no one
knew anything was wrong
for two whole days.
That means we were all
sleeping near a corpse.
A shiver runs through
me every time I think
about Dona Roza's ghost
hovering in the halls,
insulted that no one
noticed she was dead."
So, I think that's how
we do these things.
[ Applause ]
We figure out the piece of
childhood, the things that happened
to us when we're kids
that we never forget
and sometimes they're
really big things
and sometimes they're a really
small thing and then we steal them
and we stretch them and we change
them and we make them into fiction.
Is that how you do it?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
Kind of. I don't know
how I really do it.
I have no secrets.
I'm just a mess inside.
But I'll tell you this, I had to
write the forward for the anthology
and does; how many
of you are writers?
Anybody writers?
Okay. Alright, if you are a
writer you know my pain, right?
Isn't it hard drafting
that first version
of whatever you have to write?
Yeah, yeah?
Okay, if you said no,
I don't like you.
But, so I had to write the
forward for this anthology
and at first I was like "We Need
Diverse Books because it's good
for the kids" and my
editor was like, "No,
no nobody's going to read that."
I'm like, "Well, okay you
know let me do some research."
Statistics say that
blah, blah, blah, blah."
"No, no. That's not working for us."
And is say, "Okay."
>> Meg Medina: Don't
you love editors?
>> Ellen Oh: I love and
hate my editor, right?
And I said to her, "What
do you want from me?"
And she said, "Just tell us a
personal story that meant something
to you, that would kind of you
know resound in your readers,
like that they could
kind of relate to."
I said, "Okay, I'll tell
them the cat story."
And this is a true story.
When I was nine of
ten-years-old, I forget.
It's kind of a blur.
I was walking down the streets; I
grew up in Brooklyn and I also was
in one of those big like buildings
that everybody can't tell apart.
But my building had a big "No pets
allowed" sign in the lobby, right?
And I always wanted a pet.
I mean, I have, I had a baby
sister, but kind of you know,
babies they coo, they're
in the diapers all the
time, they're no fun.
I wanted a pet, and I happened
to be walking home one day
from the library, of
course, because I lived
in a library and there was a kitten.
A cute little black and white kitten
right next to the dumpster and I was
like "Oh my god this is so cute.
I'm going to name him George and
I'm going to take him home with me
and nobody will know that
I have him in my room.
My parents will never know
and I'll take care of him."
And I hid George under my shirt
and I walked the five blocks home.
Well, by the time I got home
I looked like Frankenstein.
Like I was like, he had managed
to scratch every part of my body.
My eyes were swollen shut.
I looked like boiled
eggs, you know, just like.
I had like leech marks all over
my body and I could barely see,
but I stumble into my house and
my parents are like, "Oh my!
What the heck happened!"
And I'm like, "This
is my cat George.
I love him."
And they said, "He's
trying to kill you.
You're allergic to cats."
I was like, "No."
And my parents took the cat away
and I'm like, "No George come back."
And he went arsk!
He scratched me one good time.
And the reason why I ended up
telling that story in the forward is
because literally every
family reunion
after that my parents
would be like oh the story.
"Remember that time Ellen, you know,
found a cat that tried to kill her?"
So, a now I have dogs.
I'm not allergic to dogs.
I have two dogs.
Cats hate me.
But I love that story because it
kind of tells exactly how, you know,
childhood is; children
when you're going
through life you will have
good moments and bad moments.
You will make horrendous mistakes
like picking up a stray cat
from a dumpster and then you'll
have wonderful glorious moments too
and I think kind of
like those stories.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Everyone has
them and I, we wanted a chance
to share those stories
in this anthology which.
>> Meg Medina: I want to
tell them about the title.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> Meg Medina: To me,
like do I have anyone
out here is a Soman Chainani fan?
Ah.
>> Ellen Oh: Ah.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
And so, Soman's story is called
"Flying Lessons" and it ended
up being the title of
the whole anthology.
>> Ellen Oh: "Flying Lessons.
>> Meg Medina: Which I
love and his story is
like almost directly from life.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> Meg Medina: Because
of his grandmother.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> Meg Medina: Right?
>> Ellen Oh: May I read?
Okay, I'm going to skip
ahead and do this one thing.
When you write short stories, right,
it's very different
from writing novels.
It's really, really hard which is
why I didn't write a short story
and Meg did.
So, I had the easy job.
Well, one of the things about short
stories is how quickly can you hook
the reader, right?
Now if you notice when Meg read her
story, I think as soon as she got
to the dead body part you were like
wow, I kind of need to keep reading.
Am I right?
Dead bodies kind of do that.
Alright, so let me read
you Soman's first line
of his story which is right here.
Flying Lessons; Soman Chainani.
"Nani wears a fur coat
to the beach."
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Okay, right there.
Now when he told me this story
before WNDB every came to be,
before this anthology ever came to
be, he told me Nani wore stilettos
and a fur coat to the beach and
I'm like dying with laughter.
And what's funny is that as kind
of like the kids of immigrants,
we were like telling these stories
to each other and we're laughing
and we're connecting and
I remember saying to him,
"These stories would
make a great anthology."
So fast forward a couple of months
later, WNDB happens and I say
to Soman who we happen
to be having breakfast
with our mutual editor Phoebe Yeh
and I said, "Hey, Soman remember
that story about Nani going, you're
grandmother going to the beach in a,
you know, full fur coat and
stilettos and leaving you there
on a nude beach when you
were eleven-years-old?"
And he's like "Yeah."
I said, "Can you write that
story for the WNDB anthology?"
And he's like, "Of course."
And that's how it came to be.
>> Meg Medina: I think
we all said of course.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: Like every
author that Ellen I think called
and you said "Would
you be willing to",
like before you even finished
this sentence we said yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: And I think that is
because I think all ten of us feel
so strongly that we want
everybody to see themselves
in the pages of those books.
So, to the extent that we could
write a story from our own
like race, Lin from her spot
and Jackie Woodson from hers,
and Kwame Alexander from
his, and Tim Federle,
I mean all of us our
own tiny little piece
of experience and put it out there.
I think what happens sometimes
with storybooks like this is
that kids get to, they don't maybe
connect with every single story,
but there is at least one that
has a character that they go,
"That's exactly what
it feels like to be me,
or that's exactly like
someone I know."
And that for me has
been like the fun part.
And I do love story.
I love writing short story.
Does anybody here write
shorty story at school?
Yes, I love them.
I love them because you know how
I think of them is I think of them
like paintings and
here's the difference.
When I'm writing short story,
it's like being an
impressionist painter, it's dabs.
It's little points of color and
you have to sort of stand back
from the work and then you see the
picture of the boats and the women
in the background and so
on, but when you're up close
to it you don't really see it.
You're just sort of suggesting.
Well, when you write a novel, you
have to write every last character,
you have to fill-in
every single line,
and that's a really realistic
painting, those paintings that you,
it looks like you can take
the apple right out of
that painting and eat it.
So, for me I think the beauty of the
short story is that, that it's just
like a little nugget that gives the
reader an idea of the whole world
that that kid is in and I
also like that it's short,
because sometimes reading
makes you tired, right?
I love to read but
sometimes I get tired reading,
and so when I have a book of
short storied I can read one,
I can read two, and then I'm good.
What do you love?
>> Ellen Oh: I don't
get tired reading.
>> Meg Medina: Never?
>> Ellen Oh: No.
I don't get; if I don't like
the book that's different,
but I don't get tired of reading.
I have another problem.
I'm like once I start I can't stop.
>> Meg Medina: Oh.
>> Ellen Oh: Anybody one of those?
Once I start, I cannot stop
which means four O'clock
in the morning I'm
still like reading.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Which is, you know,
which is not great, but yeah no.
I don't get tired of reading,
but I think what I love
about short stories
is that it is kind
of like a perfect microcosm
right there for you to jump in,
get to know a world
and then jump back out.
You know, and which like let's face
it, with a novel you kind of have
to have you know four, five, six
hours having; who are slow readers?
Anybody take like days to read?
Yeah. I feel you.
No, not really.
I read very fast.
I read like in a couple of
hours, but I feel the pain
of taking a longtime to read.
So, I think what short stories
do is allow you to get in and out
of that world really quickly
which is really great,
and what I like about
the short stories here is
that you have all ranges.
You can, you have the stories
that make you cry, right?
I cried when I read
Jacqueline Woodson's story;
Jackie Woodson fans here?
Yes. "Brown Girl Dreaming" should
be required reading for everyone.
She wrote the most beautiful
story in this book and I cried.
I cried even reading
Matt de la Pema's story.
Who; basketball fans,
any basketball fans?
Yes. Alright, you know, when we
talk about like how truth goes
into your fiction, Matt played
basketball, blah-blah, all his life
and he wrote a basketball story
which is just amazing, a realistic
and brilliance, and
like Kwame wrote a book
in verse of story in verse, so.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah, we're
never far from our truth I think
and there's a new anthology coming.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh yeah.
>> Meg Medina: So.
>> Ellen Oh: Young adults.
>> Meg Medina: For teens, right?
So that comes out next year.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: I think.
>> Meg Medina: Who's in it?
>> Ellen Oh: Lamar
Giles is the editor
and that will be called "Fresh Inc."
It's going to have Jason Reynolds,
Nicole Yoon, Daniel Jose Older,
Malinda Lo, Sharon Flake, Gene
Luen Yang, Eric Gansworth,
Sara Farizan, and Melissa
de la Cruz.
So there's a superstar list of
authors in that anthology too.
Yes.
>> What's it called again?
>> Ellen Oh: It's called
"Fresh Inc."
It will come out next year.
>> Meg Medina: It's called what?
>> Ellen Oh: "Fresh Inc."
>> Meg Medina: "Fresh Inc."
Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: For YA anthology.
>> Ellen Oh: Uh-hum.
For YA anthology.
What, but you know what?
Wonderful news.
Also, from "Flying Lessons" is
that Meg's story is also
going to be a novel.
Meg.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
So, when I finished
writing "Sol Paining, Inc."
Phoebe said to me, "I have a
funny feeling that these people,
that there's more to this
story than just this story."
I said, "Oh, yeah that's
interesting", and I just went away.
And then I published with Candlewick
usually and so I was contracted
for a couple of other
books, and so I started
to write this middle grade novel
that my thinking is that it's
about a young girl whose
grandfather is changing
at the same time she is changing
and it ended up being Mercy,
and Chloe [phonetic]
and all the same people;
the Suarez family come to be.
So it was really like
the opposite experience
and so I had this tiny little
morsel and I had to pullout.
But as it happens,
I've done that before.
I have a novel called, "Yaqui
Delgaldo" and that book also began
as a short story and became a novel.
So, sometimes it's just framework.
It's just sort of what I'm
changing here and there.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: So, and you have
a novel out this year also.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, yeah.
>> Meg Medina: It's scary.
>> Ellen Oh: Does anybody
like ghost stories?
Yeah, okay great.
You like really, really
scary ghost stories?
No? Who said no?
Who said no?
Okay, I'll pretend I
didn't hear that no.
I love scary stories.
I mean, like I was a kid that read
Stephen King like in the middle
of the night where I curled up
in my bed and then I had to pee
and the hallway was really dark and
I'm like, "I can't go out there.
There's a clown that's
going to kill me."
I saw many sunrises before I was
able to go the bathroom safely.
But, I wrote a; so I had
to write a ghost story
and the ghost story
I wrote is called
"Spirit Hunters" and
it's out right now.
And it's about a girl
who can see ghosts
but doesn't realize she can see
ghosts until about halfway through;
that's a little bit of a spoiler.
But while I was writing this
book, this is a true story.
Ignore the man in the
black on the stage.
While I was writing
"Spirit Hunters" I
like to write in the
middle of night.
So, it's two O'clock in the
morning and I have a dog and all
of a sudden my dog comes running
into my room and starts barking
at absolutely nothing, and I'm
like "Why are you doing that?"
>> Meg Medina: Doo, doo, doo, doo.
Doo, doo, doo, doo.
>> Ellen Oh: "Who are
you barking at?"
And then all of the
goosebumps up and down my arms.
The hair stands on my like up on my
head and I'm like there is something
in this room with me and my
dog and I cannot see them,
and I got to get the, you know,
whoops, I got to get out of there!
So, while I wrote my ghost story,
I was visited by real ghosts
and I think they were telling me
that I was doing a really good job,
because I've already had people tell
me this book is too scary for them
to read and they're adults.
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
So, I know that kids can
take it better, right kids?
>> Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Alright, yeah
we're braver than adults.
Did you notice I said "we?"
I admit it.
I am a kid at heart.
So, kids are braver than adults.
So, yeah this is a
very scary ghost story.
The adults might have to take it
with a little bit of a warning,
but yeah so that's
another true story.
I was visited by a ghost or
maybe it was my imagination.
You can take with it what you want.
>> Meg Medina: I'm
fascinated by you.
I can't stop watching
her beautiful hands.
How about you guys?
Are you finding that
you're watching her a lot?
I think it's amazing.
What do you want to know?
Questions?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, does anybody?
>> Meg Medina: Oh, but wait.
They told me that if you have
questions they'd like you
to go the microphones
on either side.
So, what would you like
to know about writing,
about any of the stories in
the book, about us as writers?
Raise your hand.
Thoughts, questions.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, go up
to the mic right there.
Uh-huh. I'm going to
steel your bing bag.
>> Meg Medina: I do
love these bing bags.
>> Ellen Oh: I know right.
>> Meg Medina: We're going
to start on this side.
>> Do you know about how
many books you've written?
>> Ellen Oh: I know
how many I've wrote.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
Alright, so you tell
them while I count mine.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, yeah I have to
count; I have written four books.
I've been three anthologies,
and I have another book coming
out next year which is;
which will have a new name,
but currently is called Soul
Eaters and it's a sequel
to "Spirit Hunters" and it's even
scarier than "Spirit Hunters."
>> Meg Medina: And I've
wrote six, and I have an,
I'll be in another anthology this
March called the "Radical Element"
for teens and my next book
based on "Sol Painting Inc."
comes out next fall.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
>> How long did it take to get like
every author's like little story?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, that's
a good question.
How long did it take me to get
everyone's story into the anthology?
Well, we gave them
deadlines but not all
of them listened to the deadlines.
So, it ranges.
We had some people give their
stories right away like within
like three to five
months and we had a few
that took like oh maybe a year.
It just kind of like depends
also on their schedules,
like a lot of authors they have
so many commitments already
that writing for us I
knew it was a big ask, so.
Thank you.
Next, uh-huh.
>> I was wondering what your
favorite horror movie was.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh-oh.
Okay, favorite horror movie was
Stephen King's "The Shining."
The movie that scared me
the most was "The Ring"
and that it was because, okay I
could not sleep for months after
"The Ring" and my kid was
like, you know, five-years-old
and had long black hair like this.
And in the middle of the night
she came over saying "Mommy."
And I have not watched a horror
movie since, but I'll read them.
>> Meg Medina: I like "Get Out."
That's my current.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
I forgot about that.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah,
That's my current favorite
and I don't like scary movies.
I hate to be scared.
I'm a big fat chicken.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> What's your favorite movie?
>> Meg Medina: Oh.
Well, I like so many movies,
but like every time I see a good
one I say, that one's my favorite,
but one that I sort of have liked
throughout many years is called
"Big Fish."
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, that's a good one.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
"Big Fish" and it's strange
and it's got magical realism
and it's got all kinds
of weird things.
You can get it, like
you can rent it,
you can download it [inaudible],
it's called "Big Fish."
How about you?
>> Ellen Oh: My favorite all time
movie is the "Princess Bride."
>> Mine's "Star Wars."
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, "Star Wars."
>> Meg Medina: "Star Wars."
Yeah. Which one?
>> The Clone Wars.
>> Meg Medina: Oh, I get it.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
Alright, this side.
Yes, hi.
>> Can you read us your scary story?
>> Ellen Oh: I can't right
now because I don't have it,
but if you want to look for it it's
in the libraries and the bookstores
and it's called "Spirt Hunters"
and hopefully maybe
sometime soon I will be able
to do a reading for
it, but thank you.
>> Okay.
>> Meg Medina: Hi.
>> Did everyone write one story or?
>> Meg Medina: Did
everyone write one story?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, uh-huh.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
I think that's what.
>> Ellen Oh: And then actually one
thing we didn't mention was we had a
short story contest where it was
open for everybody like from kids
to adults all throughout to write
a story that could be included
in the anthology and we had
a short story winner, so.
>> Meg Medina: It was Tracey.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, Tracey Baptiste,
"The Rice and Beans Chronicles."
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, yeah.
I want you guys to remember
that so the next time
if you see a short story
contest you should enter.
>> Meg Medina: Enter, enter,
enter is absolutely true.
>> Where is this information?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, on our
website; weneeddivresebooks.org.
>> What's it?
>> Ellen Oh: Weneeddiversebooks.org.
Hi.
>> What's your favorite
book that you wrote?
>> Meg Medina: Oh, you know
that's like asking your;
have you ever asked your
mother who her favorite kid is?
>> Yep.
>> Meg Medina: It never goes well.
I like different books for
different reasons, right?
So, I have a book called
"Tia Isa Wants a Car"
and I have a real Tia Isa
who still lives with me
and she really bought the first
family car, so I kind of like
that one, but I also like this
booked called, "Yaqui Delgado"
which is about bullying
which I really liked also.
Which, how about you?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, well
right now I'm going
to say my favorite book
is still "Prophecy",
because it was my first book
and also because I wrote demons
that eat your inside organs
out and then wear your skin
like a Halloween costume
and I think that's so fun,
so that's still my favorite.
Is that, is that terrible?
Oh fifteen minutes.
Okay. Thank you.
Hi.
>> Hi. So, what's your
favorite writing style?
Do you like write things down
and then forget about them
or do you write things down
when you have a complete idea
of what you're going to write?
>> Ellen Oh: Ah, that's
a good question.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah, so
I think that I do not;
I wish I were a writer
that kept a journal.
I wish I could say to
you, "I have a journal.
I keep track of everything
and then I go back
to it and pull things out."
That's not really how I work,
but I have a really great memory
which makes me a very dangerous
person to be related to.
And so, I will think on
something, I will remember myself
at a particular age and then
I sit down with a journal
and I just remember that in as much
detail as I can and I tell the truth
about it which is the tricky part.
I tell the truth about
it as much as I can.
You know, when we're adults
sometimes what we try to do
or what happens to us, is that we
remember what it is to be a kid
with a very happy face on it.
We forget like the harder
parts of being a kid.
So, when I'm writing;
when I'm remembering,
I really try to remember the
funny parts, the good parts,
but I also really try to remember
the very sad and difficult things
when you're dumped, when your
friend says they don't like you,
when you're not invited
to something,
when you don't make the
team, when you fail the test,
when you're disappointed
in your parents,
when you find out your parents
have lied, when you lie,
like all of those things
that we like to forget about.
And I write about those and then
I take them and I stretch them.
I create like I'll take two
or three people from real life
and I smoosh them together
to make one new character,
but what always has to be there
is the truth of what it felt
like to be a kid in that situation.
Everything else I make up.
How do you do it?
>> Ellen Oh: I'm an outliner.
I outline everything
and I think it's
because of my being a
lawyer for 20 years.
I have to outline and I have
conclusion and the answer is this
and that's where I write to and
my conclusion never changes.
Everything else might change
in the front or the middle,
but I write to my conclusion.
I think that's from being a lawyer
and being like oh the answer has
to be, you know, yes or no.
>> Meg Medina: What
kind of law did you do?
>> Ellen Oh: Boring law.
Very boring law.
Thank you.
Hi.
>> How long does it take
you to write a book?
>> Ellen Oh: It's a that
depends kind of question.
It took me, for "Prophecy" I
wrote a first draft in five months
and revised it for three years.
Yeah, how about you?
>> Meg Medina: I, it
really is different.
Sometimes a picture book
will take me three months,
sometimes it will take me a year.
A novel usually takes
me about three years
from the time I first have the idea
to the time I see it in a book,
and the short story, I want to
say it took like six months for me
to have, you know, work it out
a couple of times, you know,
and you know how this is.
You write the first
copy and it's terrible.
>> Ellen Oh: Yes.
>> Meg Medina: Right?
And then you have to go
back and reimagine it
and fix what's terrible
and keep working at it.
Like that thing that your
teachers do to you when they say,
"You need to revise this.
I don't understand this.
This isn't clear."
Like that never goes
away if you're a writer.
That is exactly what your
editor will do to you
as well until you get it right.
>> Thank you.
>> Ellen Oh: Hi.
>> Hi. I just have a weird question.
Do you write in the time
that the story took place
in say your life or
you write nowish?
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
Good question.
>> Ellen Oh: Well you
wrote "Burn Baby Burn."
>> Meg Medina: Both.
There's two.
You get to choose.
So you can write; when
you're writing now,
it's called contemporary, right?
So, we do write contemporary works.
Like these are all contemporary,
or most of the stories are.
>> Ellen Oh: Most of.
>> Meg Medina: Grace's is a.
>> Ellen Oh: Grace's is a; it's a
fantasy, pirate, girl pirate story.
>> Meg Medina: Right.
But, I wrote another book for high
schoolers called "Burn Baby Burn"
which is set in 1977 in New York
City, and that's historical fiction.
That's history.
And so you have to do all
the research for that.
But I'll tell you a secret,
it really doesn't matter
if you're writing historical
fiction or contemporary.
It always has to feel even
if it's historical fiction,
like it's really happening.
Even if it's in 1940, you have
to feel like you're in 1940.
>> Also, weird question; if
you're "Harry Potter" fans
which Hogwarts house are you in?
>> Ellen Oh: I'm a Ravenclaw!
>> Meg Medina: Are you?
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
>> Meg Medina: I have
not done the test.
I would say, you know, I would
say Gryffindor except they're just
so good that I'm like, "Do
I want to be that good?"
I don't know.
I know, I don't think I'd
want to be a Slytherin,
so would you let me be
a Ravenclaw with you or?
>> Ellen Oh: No I'm a Ravenclaw.
She didn't take the test.
She doesn't get to be distorted.
Sorry. Take the test.
>> Meg Medina: Fine, fine.
I see how it is Ellen Oh.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
HufflePuff.
Hi.
>> What's your favorite
story in the book?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh.
You know that question about
like who's your favorite kid?
I have three, right?
That's the same question
to ask me as an editor.
I love all of these stories for
all different reasons, but Meg.
>> Meg Medina: I have no such
consumptions so I'm going
to tell you Jackie Woodson's story
is the last one in the anthology.
It's truly beautiful.
I love that book.
I loved it.
I loved it, loved it, loved it.
They're all good, but that
for me, it was my favorite.
But favorite is like saying what's
the best flavor of ice cream, right?
>> Ellen Oh: Chocolate.
>> Meg Medina: For
somebody it's chocolate.
For somebody else it's
vanilla, strawberry, chocolate,
mint chocolate chip,
there's really no best.
It's really.
>> Ellen Oh: Chocolate.
>> Meg Medina: What sings
to your heart the most no
matter what Ellen Oh says.
>> Ellen Oh: Ravenclaw.
Hi. Thank you.
>> Hi. So, I one time flipped the
pages to part of a book one time
and it was scary that I
dropped the book and screamed
and it happened in
the school library.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh wait,
wait it was scary
because well was there a
cockroach in it or something?
>> No. So, it was night
and there was
like an owl or something and stars.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, it
was a say it again.
>> It was at night and there was
like an owl or something and stars.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh.
Was it really scary?
>> Yes.
>> Meg Medina: Night
is always scary.
>> Ellen Oh: Do you think it was
scarier because it was nighttime
or it would have been
scary any time of day?
>> I think it was would have
been scary any time of day.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, cool.
I want to know what book that is.
>> I don't know the title.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, but thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> What's your favorite book?
>> Ellen Oh: Favorite book.
>> Meg Medina: Of all time,
it was "Charlotte's Web."
I loved "Charlotte's Web"
because it was the first book
that really made me cry which
was an interesting reason
to love a book right?
Oh, good it made me cry, I like you.
That's usually a smart thing,
but until that time I
was reading like words.
I was reading to be a reader,
but with "Charlotte's Web"
that as I remember it, it was the
first book where I was like thinking
about friendship and
thinking about other things.
So, for me it was that.
>> Ellen Oh: Well, when I was.
>> Meg Medina: How about you?
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, when I was
young my favorite book was actually
"The Count of Monte Cristo" and I
think I became a lawyer because of
that book, because I
was like "revenge!"
>> Meg Medina: Do we see
a theme with Ellen Oh?
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
Hi.
>> Hello. What would you
recommend to short story writers?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, what
would we recommend?
No you go.
>> Meg Medina: What do
I; what's the question?
>> Ellen Oh: What would you
recommend for short story writers?
>> Meg Medina: Oh.
Okay, so here is really what
I would say, that the only way
to become a better writer
is just by doing it.
It's a lot like exercise.
Like when you first start to do
something you're muscles hurt,
you're taking Motrin, you're
just everything hurts you
and then you get stronger at
it and you get more coordinated
and you know what you're doing.
The same thing happens with writing,
so a lot of it is just doing it
and doing it and doing it
and getting better at it.
>> Ellen Oh: And also
reading every story.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: With anthology.
>> Meg Medina: And read,
well right and others.
I think like for me, I read;
there's not a day in my life
that I haven't read
some part of a book.
Every single day reading
is part of my life and I do
that for my own personal enjoyment,
but it also fills my toolbox
with ideas with the
way, different ways
that people have solved problems
in a book, different ways
that they've drawn characters.
So, the more you read the more
you know how to do it, but mostly,
I would say dive in, remember a good
beginning those first two paragraphs
have to grab you and
then just be brave.
Write your way through to the end.
It might be terrible and
then you have a chance
to fix it all up again.
>> Thank you.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
Next.
>> What is your favorite
horror novel?
>> Ellen Oh: Favorite horror novel.
Oh, I like "It" a lot, but
it's also why I hate clowns.
Is anybody scared of clowns?
Yeah, clowns are scary!
They're not funny.
What about you?
What's your favorite?
>> I don't have one.
>> Ellen Oh: Okay,
come back next year
and tell me what your
favorite is them.
Thank you.
Yes.
>> What's your favorite animal?
>> Ellen Oh: Favorite animal, I
think we're dog lovers up here.
>> Meg Medina: Ellen likes cats.
>> Ellen Oh: Cats hate me.
>> Meg Medina: Cats named George.
I, my favorite animal; I have two.
In the wild it's the elephant.
I love the elephant because the
head elephant is the oldest female
and she has in her mind a
memory of the entire grassland
and she leads the entire pack to
safety and where they need to be.
I love that about elephants, and
also when something bad happens
to one of the elephants,
they collect themselves
and they help each other grieve.
I just love that.
They're also just big and weird
looking, you know, I love that.
But in practical terms,
I love my dog.
His name is Hugo Menendez, and
Hugo Menendez is a black Labrador
and a Dalmatian so he's got spotted
paws and beautiful oily black skin
or fur and he is a big
chicken and I love him.
You have cute dogs.
>> Ellen Oh: I have two dogs yeah.
They drive me crazy like
my kids, but I love them.
Thank you.
Hi.
>> Who's your favorite librarian?
>> Ellen Oh: My favorite librarian
right now, Dr. Carla Hayden.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Is my
favorite librarian.
>> Meg Medina: Carla Hayden.
Woo!
[ Applause ]
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
Hi.
>> Do you write more
than one book at a time?
>> Ellen Oh: I can't even like
eat and walk at the same time.
>> Meg Medina: I've seen this.
That's true actually.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah, yeah.
>> Meg Medina: I try.
Some writers can.
Some writers love to do that
because when they get sick of one
or they get stuck, they put it
away and they go to another one
and they work on that for
a while and they can do it.
I can't do it either, because when
I'm writing a book those people
in the book feel completely
real to me.
I talk to them.
When I'm in the shower I do
dialogue like I'm with them.
I wander around the
grocery store talking scenes
until people think I crazy, and so
I have trouble pulling myself out of
that and going to another book,
but some people can do it.
We have time for probably
two or three more questions.
Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
Thank you.
>> What's the longest
book you've ever read?
>> Ellen Oh: The longest.
>> Meg Medina: Read?
Oh.
>> Ellen Oh: "Harry Potter"
which one was the middle one?
No, I think maybe "War
and Peace", right?
>> Meg Medina: Oh my gosh.
I, it had to be Leo Tolstoy.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: It was, I don't know.
"Anna Karenina" is so,
the big fat ones at.
>> Ellen Oh: Well, yeah Tolstoy.
See? Long, long, long stories.
>> Also, what's your favorite fruit?
>> Ellen Oh: Favorite fruit?
Cherries, but I'm allergic
to them and I still eat them.
I get all, and I'm
like eating them still.
Terrible.
>> Meg Medina: Long live the peach.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
>> If you had to choose one word how
would describe how much fun you had
writing the books?
>> Ellen Oh: Ahh.
One word? She's hard.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
>> Ellen Oh: That's a
mean question, one word.
Awesome. That's lame.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
You know, I feel like brotherhood.
>> Ellen Oh: Brotherhood.
Ah, that's a good one.
>> Meg Medina: Because
I felt like all
of us together we're
pulling together
to create this beautiful thing.
>> Ellen Oh: I agree.
Thank you.
That's a great question.
Hi.
>> Meg Medina: Hi.
>> Hi. My question is what's your
favorite "Harry Potter" character?
>> Ellen Oh: Hermione.
>> Meg Medina: Hermione.
Come on. Hermione.
You know.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
>> Meg Medina: He's the only
one who knew everything.
>> Ellen Oh: One last
question maybe.
>> Meg Medina: Yes, this is it.
Or no, two more right?
There's one child, yeah.
>> What was the book that
inspired you to write these?
>> Ellen Oh: Oh.
>> Meg Medina: "The House on
Mango Street" by Sandra Cisneros.
It was the first book that I saw
Latino girl and her family in it
and I read it and it thought, oh
my gosh my [foreign words spoken]
and my neighborhood, like it
could be a book, and it was,
it changed everything for me.
How about you?
>> Ellen Oh: Well, for me wanted
to write because of "Harry Potter."
Oh, I know.
Like a lot of children's authors
say that, but it really was to me
so mind-blowing to read
"Harry Potter", yeah.
Thank you.
We'll have one last question.
>> What's the first
book you ever read?
>> Ellen Oh: You know,
we're kind of old.
>> Meg Medina: Speak
for yourself sister.
>> Ellen Oh: First book we read, uh.
>> Meg Medina: I think
I read way back,
I mean really the very first things
were the Dick and Jane readers.
>> Ellen Oh: Oh, yeah!
>> Meg Medina: Right?
See Sally.
Sue; See Sue.
>> Ellen Oh: See Spot run.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
That kind of thing.
That's how they taught
us reading back then.
Ay, yi, yi, yi, yi.
>> Ellen Oh: Three boring stories.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Ellen Oh: Yeah.
That was it.
>> Meg Medina: That was
literally the first thing.
>> Ellen Oh: Thank you.
>> Meg Medina: Okay.
>> Ellen Oh: I think
we're done right?
>> Meg Medina: You've
been so wonderful.
>> Ellen Oh: You've been wonderful.
Thank you!
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.